good morning John it's been a very busy
science week and I feel as if a
particular science story has been
totally missed but maybe in fact the
biggest one of all of them like bigger
than maybe room temperature
superconductors bigger than maybe a
really powerful solid tumor cancer
treatment it's hiding and nobody's
talking about it and it is that we might
Now understand what caused this which is
a graph of the temperature of the
surface of the North Atlantic Ocean many
different years uh and that this year in
red which isn't particularly fun to look
at like in scary times here on planet
Earth but before I jump into all of this
Johnny I just want to say thank you for
your lovely yesterday video I love you
too it's been quite a year though I am
happy with the current trajectory at
least so geoengineering is this fairly
controversial idea that you could
intentionally change the climate of the
planet now that is different from when
you accidentally change the climate of
the planet which is just the last
hundred years this conversation is going
to be a big deal it's going to be a
bigger and bigger and bigger deal over
the next few decades as we have to make
really hard decisions about what to do
about the actual impacts we are
experiencing from climate change we have
very clearly been doing a lot of
accidental and Reckless and haphazard
geoengineering over the last hundred
years the biggest piece of that is dump
in a whole lot of carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere and thus decreasing the
amount of heat that can radiate back out
to space that means more heat in the
system and a hotter plant but there's
also a lot of other pieces of
geoengineering that we've been doing for
example we release a lot of sulfur
dioxide when we burn dirty fuels like
coal and fuel oil and sulfur dioxide
actually temporarily for a very short
period of time much shorter than the
impacts of carbon dioxide can decrease
the temperature of an area of the planet
it does this because it's good at
seeding clouds and it does that by
combining with moisture in the
atmosphere to form droplets of sulfuric
acid which you know you don't really
want in the air but it does create more
and fluffier clouds this is a known
effect this is not new information this
happens when volcanoes erupt and sulfur
dioxide comes out it can cool the planet
with the dust and with the silver
dioxide now one really big source of
sulfur dioxide is those big ships that
carry cargo containers from one
continent to another they burn the kind
of oil that's left over after
everybody's done taking the fraction
that they want out of it it's like the
worst cheapest oil that's what they use
it has a lot of sulfur in it they burn
it and that sulfur dioxide goes in the
atmosphere and it seeds clouds you can
actually see them from space they're
called ship tracks and they are clouds
that are created by sulfur dioxide being
spat up from the stacks of these big
ships now I don't know if you already
see where I'm going with this but this
is absolutely wild but because sulfur
dioxide is bad for people and animals
and the Earth the un's international
Maritime organization passed a new rule
that said you have to burn low sulfur
fuels in these big ships that rule went
into effect in 2020 and over the last
few years there have been significantly
fewer ship tracks scientists have been
looking at this really carefully and
their mod models are showing that like
almost all of the new warming of the
North Atlantic surface of the sea can be
attributed to just new light hitting it
that wouldn't normally be hitting it now
that's mostly because of ship tracks and
partially because this year there was
just less dust from the Sahara for I
think unrelated reasons so in one way
this is very bad news like it turns out
global warming is worse than we thought
it was we were just being shielded from
some of its effects by other pollution
that we were throwing up into the
atmosphere but in another way and I
think a bigger way in the long term this
is good news because the experiment that
we just ran here is
Priceless and also impossible to pull
off like if we had wanted to run this
experiment it would have been so
expensive that we never could have done
it but it also would be politically
impossible to pull off because
geoengineering is such a hot button
issue instead we got a perfect
experiment showing us the effects of
local geoengineering on this area and
the thing is you don't have to use
sulfur dioxide to seed Cloud there's
other ways to do it that don't involve a
bunch of acid rain and giving people
asthma one of the ways is to just shoot
sea water into the air there's a bunch
of seawater around you shoot it up into
the air with like misters that make it
like super tiny so it can float in the
atmosphere just like any other particle
most of the water evaporates leaving
behind little crystals of salt that then
concede clouds and then it falls back
down and the ocean's like yeah that was
the salt that was here in the first
place some people say that we can't
discuss geoengineering because people
will see it as an excuse to continue
just burning fossil fuels I don't think
anybody's gonna see it that way in 10 or
20 years it's gonna be very hot it's
gonna get hot enough that we're gonna
see a lot of marine extinctions it's
gonna get hot enough that we're going to
see a lot of humans dying those stories
are going to be very big in other parts
of the world but they're also going to
be like local stories in the U.S like
people we're gonna have people here
dying of heat and we have to do like
three things at the same time we have to
stop putting new carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere we have to start taking old
CO2 out of the atmosphere and we have to
deal with the impacts of the current
warming which exists now and we cannot
avoid we are entering into the overlap
period the period during which the
problem is big enough that we can't
ignore it anymore and when we still can
do things to solve it and that means all
three of those things so to have a
natural decades-long experiment like
this is priceless and maybe even more
than that we can see that we're already
doing it instead of saying should
humanity take this giant step forward
and begin geoengineering the planet what
we're saying is should we take a giant
step forward and do it instead of
accidentally and haphazardly and in the
most Reckless manner possible do it
intentionally and carefully
John I'll see you on Tuesday intentional
and careful is also a lot of what the
awesome coffee Club is doing so a lot of
places and a lot of people just sort of
look for the certifications but we've
actually gone to talk to and visit with
the people who make this coffee because
coffee is one of the great joys of life
and this coffee is amazing because it's
extraordinarily high quality because it
is taken care of from the moment the
tree is planted in Colombia to the
moment that it's shipped out of our
warehouse in Missoula Montana there's a
link in the description or you can just
Google awesome coffee Club you know how
the internet works